القوات الروسية بصوت واحد
شكرا أمريكا، لقد استولينا على صواريخكم
موسكو لا تكتفي بالصواريخ الأمريكية فقط،
وتفرض عقوبات على بايدن وبلينكن
وهيلاري كلينتون، فروسيا تعمل بمبدأ
السن بالسن ردا على العقوبات الأمريكية،
..سقوط أكبر مدن أوكرانيا بيد قوات روسيا،
.. رئيس الشيشان ينضم للحلبة،،
بايدن يعلن تخصيص 13 مليار دولار
كمساعدات عسكرية وإنسانية لكييف...
لكنه يعود وينفي فرض منطقة حظر جوي
فوق أوكرانيا،..
فهل يساعد الأمريكان الأوكران فقط
من أجل أن يكونوا ضحايا لاستمرار الحرب،
هل هذا هو الدعم الأمريكي؟ ..
جلسة استثنائية للناتو فهل تأتي بجديد؟..
موقف الصين تعتريه الضبابية
في أمريكا والقلق يزداد،..
زيارات رسمية لزعماء دول أوروبية
لكييف فهل تكون باباً لزيارات أخرى
أم تكون هي الزيارة الأولى والأخيرة
خلال هذه الحرب؟
قوات روسية تستولي على صواريخ
جافلين الأمريكية  خلال معارك
مع الجيش الأوكراني.. وتعزيزات أمريكا
تتجه ليد العدو،
فرضت موسكو عقوبات شخصية
على الرئيس الأميركي جو بايدن"،
وأدرجت وزير الخارجية الأميركي
أنتوني بلينكن في قائمة "المحظورين".
كما فرضت موسكو عقوبات على وزيرة الخارجية
الأميركية السابقة هيلاري كلينتون،
وفق بيان الخارجية الروسية،
التي لفتت إلى أنّ "العقوبات على عدد
من المسؤولين الأميركيين هي رد
على العقوبات المفروضة على المسؤولين الروس".
وأوضحت وزارة الخارجية الروسية
أنّ "العقوبات تنطبق أيضاً على وزير الدفاع الأميركي
ومستشار الأمن القومي ورئيس "سي آي إيه"".
وهنا بايدن يعلن تخصيص ١٣.٦ مليار دولار
كمساعدات عسكرية وإنسانية في أوكرانيا..
وبحسب مسؤول أمريكي الرئيس  جو بايدن
يعلن عن تقديم مساعدة أمنية جديدة لأوكرانيا
بقيمة 800 مليون دولار
، بعد وقت قصير على إلقاء الرئيس الأوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي كلمة أمام الكونغرس.
(سيناريوهات الحرب)
الحرب في أوكرانيا ستقتصر بين ٣ سيناريوهات
الأول: هو السيناريو الأجمل بالنسبة للعالم،
وهو حل القضية سلميا عبر المفاوضات..
لكن يبدو أن هذا الخيار هو الأصعب
إن لم يكن مستحيلا مع رفض الكرملين
لمطالب أوكرانيا، وصعوبة استجابة أوكرانيا
لشروط روسيا ..
الخيار الثاني:
وهو الخيار الأكثر واقعية على الأرض،
وذلك باستمرار الحرب لفترة طويلة،
وبذلك ستسيطر روسيا على مساحات
شاسعة في أوكرانيا، واستمرار القوات الروسية
بقتل أعدائها الأوكران،
وسوف تتدمر البلاد بأكملها..
الخيار الثالث :
الخيار الأكثر شؤما في الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية
، قد تتواجه روسيا وهي إحدى أقوى الدوى في العالم
في مواجهة مباشرة لأي سبب كان
مع حلف الناتو أقوى حلف دفاعي في العالم،
وهناك ستكون الكارثة وبداية للحرب العالمية الثالثة،
(الصين أكبر مخاوف أمريكا)
مخاوف غربية من تقديم الصين الدعم العسكري
لروسيا،  وتقارير أمريكية تفيد أن روسيا
طلبت الدعم من حلفائهم الصينيين،،
لكن موسكو تنفي هذه الأخبار وتقول
أنها تمتلك القوة اللازمة للقضاء على أعدائها
في أوكرانيا، وليست بحاجة لدعم خارجي،،
لكن تبقى الصين هي القلق الأكبر لدى الأمريكان،
فمسؤولو البيت الأبيض يطلقون التصريحات
بين الترغيب والترهيب لبكين بعدم دعم روسيا،
لكن يظل الموقف ضبابيا في الوقت الحالي،
بدون رد صريح من قيادة بكين...
(المصير ذاته)
تايوان تعيش المخاوف التي تعاني منها أوكرانيا
،، وبرغم تعهد الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
بحماية تايوان، إلا أن الصين قد تسلك طرق
القوة مقتدية بحليفتها روسيا،
بغزو تايوان والاستيلاء عليها بالقوة،،
لذلك فالجيش التايواني يجري تدريبات
ومناورات عسكرية ويستدعي قوات الاحتياط،
وسبق لبايدن أن تعهد بحماية تايوان
من التنين الصيني لكن هل يكون عهد الرئيس الأمريكي
كلاما أطلقه في الهواء،
كما حدث ويحدث في أوكرانيا..
(الأحداث والتطورات)
القوات الروسية تسيطر على خيرسون
أكبر مدينة أوكرانية مأهولة بالسكان..
وسائل إعلام أوكرانية: سفن حربية
روسية تتحرك في البحر الأسود،
استعدادا للهجوم على أوديسا،،
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تنشر فيديو رهيب
لمسيرة روسية تدمر معدات عسكرية
في تشرنيهيف..
أول زيارة أوروبية لكييف منذ بدء الحرب،
وتعهد بمواصلة الدعم لأوكرانيا،
حيث التقى رؤساء وزراء بولندا وسلوفينيا
وجمهورية التشيك بالرئيس الأوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي مع بدء حظر تجول في كييف..
بينما خرج زيلينسكي بعدها ليدعو إلى القيام
بمزيد من الزيارات الرسمية لكييف.
أمين عام حلف الناتو ستولتنبرغ:
نراقب الوضع في أوكرانيا وقياداتنا العسكرية
تتواصل مع روسيا لتلافي أي أحداث خاطئة...
الناتو أوكرانيا لها كل الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها
وسنواصل تقديم كل الدعم لها،
كما دعا الحلف الصين إلى عدم دعم خطوات
روسيا وإدانة عملياتها العسكرية في أوكرانيا،
فما هو موقف أصحاب العيون الضيقة؟
وكانت وزارة الدفاع التركية قد أعلنت أن وزراء
دفاع دول الناتو سيعقدون جلسة استثنائية
في بروكسل ، لتقييم التطورات في أوكرانيا.
بايدن يستبعد فرض منطقة حظر جوي،
محذرا من أن ذلك سيجر الى مواجهة
كارثية مع روسيا.
رئيس الشيشان يشارك في حلبة مصارعة
(إيلون ماسك مع فلاديمير بوتين)
رمضان قديروف مخاطبا إيلون ماسك
(لا أنصحك بالتنافس مع بوتين،
لأنك ستتلقى هزيمة شنيعة،
أقترح عليك تدريبات في الجيش الشيشاني)
ليرد ماسك على ذلك بتغريدة كتب فيها
(شكرا لك على العرض، لكن مثل هذا التدريب الممتاز
سيمنحني الكثير من المزايا،
إذا كان بوتين خائفا من القتال، فسأوافق
على استخدام يدي اليسرى فقط،
وللعلم أنا لست أعسر،،
وزارة الدفاع البريطانية:
تكتيكات الدفاع الأوكرانية أحبطت القوات الروسية
وألحقت بها خسائر فادحة ..
صور للمروحة الروسية التي تسمى
(القرش الأسود) وهي تقصف وتضرب
الأراضي الأوكرانية..
لافروف: نحن مع الوقف الفوري للحرب
لكنها لن تنتهي قبل القضاء على الراديكاليين
القوميين الأوكرانيين..
مستشار عمدة ماريوبول يحذر أن عدد القتلى
قد يصل إلى ٢٠ألفا من المواطنين
والجنود الأوكران بحسب قوله
"أننا ندفن الموتى في الساحات والشوارع"
. بينما يؤكد الروس ضرب أهدافهم العسكرية فقط
بعيدا عن المدنيين،،
ضغوط داخلية وخارجية على إدارة بايدن
لتزويد أوكرانيا بمنظومات دفاع صاروخية،،
فهل تجرؤ الإدارة الأمريكية على خطوة كهذه
قد تجرها إلى الحرب مباشرة مع الدب الروسيّ
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تعلن تدمير ١٣٦
منشأة عسكرية خلال ٢٤ ساعة ماضية فقط،،،
بينما
ترد كييف بإسقاط،
٦ طائرات روسية منها ٤ مروحيات هيلوكوبتر ،
وكييف تتلقى قصفا عنيفا من القوات المحاصرة لها..
المجلس الأوروبي يعلن حظر الاستثمارات
الجديدة في قطاع الطاقة الروسي
بلينكن، أوكرانيا لم تكن بصدد الانضمام
لحلف الناتو حتى قبل العدوان الروسي عليها..
بعد فتح روسيا المجال للقوات الأجنبية للقتال
معها في أوكرانيا، قوات سورية تابعة
للرئيس بشار الأسد تستعد لدخول الحرب في أوكرانيا..
المفاوضات مستمرة،، ورئيس الوفد التفاوضي
الروسي يقول، شرطنا بأن تكون كييف محايدة
والمفاوضات تتواصل،،،
نائبة وزير الخارجية الأمريكي:
بوتين لم يظهر أي إشارة إلى أنه راغب
في إنهاء الحرب
قصف مستمر يستهدف المنطقة الشمالية للعاصمة الأوكرانية كييف،
المساعدات الغربية تتوالى،
والمراشقات بالعقوبات تزداد بين الطرفين
الأمريكي والروسي،
ومخاوف الغرب تكثر مع الوقت،
لكن قوات الدب الروسي تستمر بالتقدم،
فمن يستطيع إيقافها؟
....